when it came to the duke even a brief
meeting could provide
a lifelong anecdote we asked people to
send us their memories
our inbox was inundated with stories
like
sonal dharmabandu's memories of salon
now sri lanka
in 1954 when the queen and prince philip
visited
the reception for the queen and prince
philip
was well underway i was eight
i managed to lose my way and lost my
parents
then came a policeman and took me by my
hand
and took me to the tent where the public
had the system was installed
so everything was stopped to make an
announcement
uh asking my parents to come and pick me
up so when my father came up
very close to where the queen and prince
william proceeded to take me
back to where they were i was not
interested in seeing the queen i was so
pleased to have been able to
see my parents back after a year where
there's been so much loss
and so much grief it might seem
startling
that the death of a 99 year old man
could cause so many people to stop
pause and reflect but perhaps it speaks
to the duke's longevity
to the breadth of his interests and his
character
that an encounter with him seems
difficult to forget
imam karyasi met him at buckingham
palace in 2005 with a group of other
faith leaders
it was an extraordinary meeting in that
that he used his
written wisdom to communicate he was
very considerate
but also very knowledgeable about other
religions
some didn't even have to meet the duke
to be struck by him
harry emmett from ackerington is a hobby
photographer
in 1977 harry and friends wrote to
buckingham palace
they asked if they could use some
wildlife photographs taken by the duke
in their camera club's annual exhibition
at this local art gallery
i received a phone call from norman
potter who was at the time curator
at the highway gallery who said
i've just had a phone call about you
from buckingham palace
you know the duke london buckingham
palace
i crington the fact that
we had been recognized and been trusted
to take these photographs
um it was quite a surprise yeah my
father was working out in the um in the
middle east of the iraq trailing company
around the early
1960s and him and his best friend were
doing up a boat
a flying 15 boat which required a total
overhaul so they needed some sales so
they wrote the
uk flying 15 association seeing if
anyone had any sales they could send out
uh and then about three or four weeks
later they got this parcel
in the post with a handwritten letter
none other than the duke of edinburgh
saying here's some sales you know enjoy
it i hope you have good fun with it
which i thought was a
lovely touch for someone who's so busy
my father was um
commanding officer on the trinity house
patricia at the time
in um hence he was obviously hosting
hosting the duke on board
it must have been nearly 20 years later
my father got invited to
um the garden party at buckingham palace
and he was able to take
two children so i went along whilst
uh the duke came down his line he
actually broke away from his equity
made a beeline for my dad and he came
over and
had quite an informal chat with us all
which was really really lovely
the duke was described to us today as a
legend
his legacy certainly hard to forget
catherine of totsi sky news